obsidian entertainment and paradox
interactive have announced a new role
playing game for PC called tyranny I'm
Lucy and welcome to your fantasy
gamespot news update her game is set in
an original fantasy world where a brutal
clash between good and evil has taken
place and evil emerged triumphant the
game story will be nonlinear and see
players make difficult morally unclear
decisions in tyranny evil forces led by
a character named kyros the overlord
have won a grand war players will step
into the role of an officer in kairos
forces where they will be able to
interact with the populace to inspire
loyalty disgust or fear as they explore
the game's world tyranny is scheduled to
release sometime this year and players
who are interested can subscribe to the
official site for more information
developer obsidian entertainment
released isometric fantasy role-playing
game pillars of eternity in March 2015
the studios also worked on a variety of
games including Fallout New Vegas south
park the stick of truth and neverwinter
nights 2 they're currently working on
armored warfare for PC which currently
does not have a scheduled release date
so do you like the look of tyranny let
me know in the comments below or come
find me on Twitter I'm at Lucy James
games for more keep it gamespot
you